[Musica]
buongiorno come ha spiegato il
presentatore è un tracciato di vita
molto particolare ovviamente io ho una
scoglio sotto 12 70 a monterotondo un
paese della provincia di roma è
praticamente la mia fase di esperienze
nel mondo lavorativo viste delle
attitudini che io avevo già scoperto in
me stesso e inizia già a 18 19 anni nel
settore della comunicazione tra le altre
cose con con uno scontro molto
importante nel senso conobbi nelle
letture card jasper del quale poi cito
una massima che è tutto ciò che non si
può comunicare non esiste nella realtà
che per me è stato un po diciamo così la
persona che ha ispirato tutto quello che
è stato il percorso già 22 anni ero
titolare dell'aspetto spazio sport una
società che si occupava di spazi
pubblicitari esclusivista al centro
italia per dubitare da una serie di
esperienze molti cose perché mi resi
conto da subito che le attitudini erano
importanti che riuscivo a raggiungere
dei traguardi anche anche seri
l'unica l'unica problematica che poi è
problematica che darà vita tutta la
serie di esperienze consecutive nelle
quali mi sono trovato e che non ho avuto
un mentore ovviamente e quindi ho
spaziato vorticosamente in tutti quei
settori della comunicazione e del
marketing
da autodidatta e quindi con le
conseguenze del caso
niente iniziai da ghost writer nel
settore cinematografico
affianco ad alcuni personaggi fino ad
arrivare alle pubbliche relazioni
a dirigere un gruppo di lavoro è però
ovvio che in questo vortice che si viene
a creare di esperienze che non hanno in
realtà ai delle ambizioni ma non hai un
obiettivo preciso cioè non riesce ad
inquadrare esattamente qual è
l'obiettivo da raggiungere
sì la missione spinge ad andare avanti a
costruire sempre di più a creare sempre
più situazioni lavorative di crescita
però purtroppo questo problema di non
avere avuto la guida fa perdere di vista
gli obiettivi
durante questo vortice di esperienze si
vanno a creare anche ovviamente degli
errori che lì per lì to tralasci perché
perché ovviamente 6 e diretto come un
treno a raggiungere quelle che sono le
tue ambizioni di conseguenza tralasci
tralasci costruisci costruisci e ad un
certo punto mi sono trovato nel 2008
quasi all'apice tra l'altro della mia
carriera d'agosto manager perché non
sono stato un manager
la ribalta da grandi luci però ero
arrivato a dirigere un gruppo di lavoro
importante ad avere dei partners
importanti e un certo punto gli errori
che ho accumulato sono venuti a bussare
alla porta e inevitabilmente ho dovuto
accettare quella che era la realtà si
era creato un debito con le istituzioni
che sono stato costretto per scelta a
pagare ovviamente sono entrato nel
circuito detentivo
questo è un percorso molto difficile
perché ovviamente si passa da quello che
è uno status quo di libertà di di libero
movimento di libero arbitrio a una
situazione nella quale ovviamente si
deve sottostare a delle regole
fondamentali
però devo dire l'esperienza che io ho
fatto e come l'ho vissuta specialmente
all'interno della casa rieducativa santo
spirito qui di siena mi ha fatto
comprendere delle cose fondamentali
allora la prima che molto probabilmente
era arrivato il momento visto che io non
riuscivo attirare attirare proprio un
freno perché ormai ero si era bello
raggiungere dei risultati vedere che
imprenditori investivano vedere che le
società comunque chiamavano però
ovviamente ero così l'obiettivo era
sempre quello che mancava in questa
esperienza di educativa specialmente
all'interno del carcere di siena e ho
potuto diciamo proiettare quello che poi
è un regime molto difficile perché
ovviamente ripeto passare dalla libertà
ha un'esperienza questo tipo non è
facile perché perché si sottostà a delle
regole importanti che però mi hanno dato
il tempo e modo non solo di riflettere
organizzare il mio tempo riguardare un
pochino ritroso quella che è la mia vita
ma oltre a quello è proprio questa fase
educativa questo istituto
mi ha dato la possibilità di focalizzare
gli obiettivi perché ovviamente mi è
stato detto allora facciamo una cosa noi
collaboriamo con la uil unione italiana
ciechi dobbiamo preparare delle dei cd
di vetture per questa associazione è
tanto è vero che poi ne è uscito una
delle uno dei cd che noi abbiamo
prodotto e le fiabe di santo spinge ad
altri racconti e lì ovviamente che cosa
è accaduto
e accaduto che intanto è continuata la
comunicazione cosa fu un fondamentale
perché per me oggi essere qui è come un
po ripartire in quella direzione che
avevo lasciato però la cosa fondamentale
è che questa fase rieducativa ti mette
degli obiettivi davanti e questa è una
cosa molto importante perché perché non
c'è più il dispendio di energie perché
sai da dove di ripartire e dove nevi
arrivare che è una cosa fondamentale
perché il dispendio di energie può
causare tutto quello che io sto dicendo
tutto quello che purtroppo è capitato a
me nella vita sia nelle fortune che
nelle disgrazie perché non è stata una
vita della quale ho rimpianti o rimorsi
anzi devo dire che il percorso è stato
veramente notevole poi ovviamente gli
errori fatti hanno un prezzo
come si guadagna bisogna anche pagare in
questa fase
si sta crescendo si sta fanno molte
attività all'interno dell'istituto che
ci permettono comunque un confronto
quotidiano con quello che è il sociale
esterno quindi si vive in maniera molto
giusta quello che è il periodo di
rieducazione ma la fortuna mia spero
anche di tanti altri che vivono questa
esperienza di tanti altri probabilmente
no è quella di decidere realmente di
tornare a quello che è un percorso sano
e che porti ovviamente a riprendere la
propria vita ai propri affetti il
proprio lavoro lì da dove si è
interrotto da una parte devo dire
l'esperienza mi è servita molto anche
perché nel tracciato precedente comunque
sono stato apprezzato da molti
imprenditori che hanno capito quello che
è avvenuto da partners e internazionali
che li hanno manifestato la loro fiducia
con e mail con comunque di riscontri
oggettivi e che ovviamente mi porterà al
momento in cui il mio inserimento sarà
avvenuto pienamente riprendere il mio
percorso non proprio esattamente da dove
l'aveva lasciato ma comunque are
intraprendere quella quel percorso che
io ritengo fantastico che è la
comunicazione che
il marketing che sono sono stati quando
io ho iniziato la facoltà di scienze
della comunicazione di torino fu la
facoltà coloro che tiravano fuori questa
questo questa diciamo il futuro di
quello che poi oggi viviamo nella
comunicazione e poi si trasferì ad
urbino 9 è la storia la sappiamo insomma
ma la cosa più importante è questa è che
bisogna saper vivere ogni esperienza che
la vita ci da riuscire a non disperdere
le energie perché il mio è stato quello
più che altro il problema un dispendio
di energie non mirato senza obiettivi
anche se produttivo ma ha prodotto sia
cose buone che cose negative giustamente
quando ho avuto da prendere i frutti li
ho presi ne ho voluto al momento che ho
dovuto pagare con gli errori fatti da
uomo ho affrontato questa cosa e li ho
pagati
ringrazio e sono onorato di essere qui
al cospetto di tutti voi di questa
grande possibilità che la direzione
della cc santo spirito mi ha dato e che
dire buona fortuna e giuseppe alto rango
roma
[Applauso]
[Musica]